muscles mostly important the browser
when I charted with the using mass I
expected using you know I could
understand what what happening the
nature because I using the equations I I
tried to explain what happening that
nature you know using one equation and
and so that my feeling of the mass and
what's the same time you know I'm
assuming the mass is used to explain the
nature nor hmes or data or all kinds of
things happening so and most important
the mass press also people hostage of
the interest of the nature to understand
the nature we need mass and and also
physics must meet the physics and so
charging for the most simple say Chad
children has to play outside to
understand what happening in nature and
also also to serve to understand nature
and Irene D some to like a mass so and
to Therese mass and also garage I must
become physics physics also become the
to restrict spend on H nature so I think
those combination is important for
childhood just I pray outside to
understand their joint study maths and
physics yeah